so just who is Marion Cotillard I really
love American movies not only does the
French actress look like Angelina she's
also an Oscar winner and a mom soon to
be raising two kids with her longtime
partner um kanay they got together in
2007 and like Brad and Angie they met on
a movie set when he was still married to
actress Diane Kruger
and also like Julie Marion is an award
show vet I'm very happy in 2008 et was
there after coach er won a Golden Globe
for LA vegan rose at the SAG Awards the
nominee praised her competition
including Jolie to have a nomination
amongst these amazing actresses it is
something huge then she took home the
Oscar a 2009 Academy Awards when Brad
and Antonia were both nominated Marion
was there she even presented Angie's
Best Actress category but coach ER has
always been associated with Hollywood's
a-list Marion earned a globe Nam for her
sexy role alongside Nicole Kidman and
Penelope Cruz and nine
she played Leo's wife in Inception an
Owen Wilson's love interest in Midnight
in Paris but besides acting like
Angelina coach ER is also a face and
fashion frenzy campaigns for Lady Dior
and she's also an activist like Jolie
Mary Ann has been a longtime
spokesperson for Greenpeace I'm not
modest I just think you know I turn my
best
you